you want to rehabilitate a partner
yeah i didn't know how to how else to
put it uh thanks for putting me on by
the way this is the first time
um so basically i i got married about
two three years ago
um before i found the red the quality
red pill stuff uh before i was doing rsd
and all that stuff um and uh got married
before once divorced did the whole five
years kind of on my own thing uh fell
into this one so when i met
that's correct yeah
so
um what what i mean by rehabilitating is
i really just discovered through rollo
through you fresh and fit basically kind
of figured out who needs to be that i
need to be more of a leader and she
needs to kind of be more of a follower
um and she's agreed to that it's very
interesting because she's traditional
like in a sense that she kind of grew up
in asia
grew up there and came over here but i
suspect that through the years of living
on her own
um and just pursuing a degree and all
that stuff she's kind of exhibiting a
lot of masculine behavior and she's
aware of that but how old was she when
she came here
who she was uh 22 i think how old is she
now she's 34. you guys have any kids
yes
okay how many kids yeah one
uh and what behavior are you trying to
re rehabilitate are you trying to
squeeze the masculine energy out of her
or something what it is sometimes she'll
take she'll try to take over and like
start like ordering me around and stuff
and it's not so much as the
it's not the request itself um it's more
of the the attitude behind it have you
met her parents
i have
and how do they behave with one another
what's their interaction like very
traditional the mother is very
supportive um
maybe harsh in the not harsh but
hardcore in the beginning because she um
she's very successful musician who wears
the pants in the household the father or
the mother
wow that's a great question i would say
the father when it comes to things
outside the home but inside the home
it's the mother i think because it's her
household so
so the thing you got to understand guys
when you're dealing with women is that
their ideal view of a relationship when
it's a two-parent household you know mom
and dad is they're generally going to
mimic the behavior or they're going to
try to take that unplug it from their
parents and plug it into their own
relationship so
a long time ago before i was
unplugged wrote my book read any of the
red pill [ __ ] i was dating this girl
and i remember we went over around the
holidays and her mom was
running the old man like she was telling
him to do this and that and the other
thing and it's like
there was a rock in the backyard like
this is around christmas time there's a
big ass rock and she's like i need you
to go outside and move this rock
right it's like i'm thinking of myself a
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] christmas chill out
right and it's like i started to watch
the behavior and then i saw
my girlfriend behaving in some ways a
lot like the mom and i was like i'm out
like my spidey senses were tingling i
was like
we're done i'm not i'm not playing this
game you know homie don't roll that way
now you're already married to her so i'm
just explaining that to you so that you
can understand the dynamic a little bit
better this is this is just going to be
a little bit more work you're just going
to have to be you know that that guy
that that she's going to be willing to
yield to
right which means you've got to be the
leader like you've got to be that
stand-up leader in the household like
you have to pass the [ __ ] test
yeah and it's just a constant thing like
it's um it's going to be constant for a
while
there are lucid moments though like we
had like you know come to jesus moments
a lot of times and so she's very aware
and sometimes she's been improving like
she'll rebound meaning she'll i don't
have to correct her sometimes and she'll
kind of come around and kind of give a
little bit more that feminine energy but
i feel like there's sometimes i get
really tired because you know i have to
basically like work
sometimes i think in the back of my head
man if i had just selected
someone that's a little bit more kind of
you know not as programmed um a
particular way that they my life would
be so much easier and that's a dangerous
thought like it's like it's basically
the thought of giving up it's not a it's
not a it's not a
strong mentality so
listen sir you know women want to be
with a leader they want to look up to a
guy and the only reason why she should
test you the only reason why she leans
into this masculine crap is because
toxic feminism taught her in north
america that that's what women should
behave like
you have to take her back to the point
where it's like
no
this is my house
okay my house is my castle
and
and like every time she comes at you
with a [ __ ] test grab your bat you wind
up and knock it out of the park
okay and it's gonna be work it's gonna
be exhausting man like you're gonna like
you're not gonna
you're gonna find yourself you know
getting frustrated having to deal with
the constant flurry of [ __ ] tests but
what are your options get divorced and
then deal with sharing custody of your
kid and losing half your [ __ ] we're
trying to fix this so that you're in the
leadership role i can't wave a magic
wand and you know flash it you know in
front of the camera and solve your
problem there's work that needs to be
done on your part and that's just really
you know maintaining the frame in the
relationship at any time she's throwing
the competency test because all she's
doing is she's basically trying to make
sure is this guy the best that i can do
is he the most competent man that i can
be with right that's that's why women
should test dudes right you just have to
deal with it like on every little
occasion
and if she and if she disparages you if
she does anything to try to
you know that's like underhanded then
you have to deal with it right you have
to deal with it you're never going to
talk to me like that ever again yeah i
call it out which i call it out it's
it's it's never gotten it's that part
has gotten better because i don't look
i'm not your
subordinate at the office like you're
not your mom and i'm not your father
like you're not going to talk to me like
that okay this is my house i want to
make that clear right so
like i said i mean you're just going to
have some work to do on this that's all
yeah
all right thanks rich all right man
you